اذا سيكون معنا الان الناقد الفني طارق
الشناوي في فقره جدل دراما اهلا بك استاذ
طارق معنا في مساء العربيه حقيقه اليوم
نتحدث عن جدل قبل رمضان وجدل بعد رمضان
وجدل خلال رمضان يعني نحن الان في الايام
الاولى من رمضان ودائما نسمع هذا الجدل
على السوشيال ميديا بين الناس فيما يتعلق
بالاعمال الدراميه نبدا معك من دفعه لندن
ماذا نقول في هذا الخصوص
الحياه هي ليست جديده
دائما في اي اعمال دراميه بتقدم
يعني وجهين للعمله او صراع ما خفي او قديم
او حتى مش صراع ولكن مجرد في اكتر من
جنسيه موجوده فبيبقى رد الفعل في حساسيه
من الاطراف كلها يعني زي مثلا لما بنيجي
نعمل في مصر زي فيلم حسن ومرقص هتلاقيه
الكاتب لجا عشان ده المسلم والمسيحي لنوع
من التركيبه الهندسيه وده اسوا حاجه في
الدراما انك انت تبقى هندسي قوي يعني قطع
هنا وخطا هناك ميزه هنا وميزه هناك وتصور
ان دفعه لندن لما شفته ما لقيت ما لقيتش
الحساسيه اللي عندي بعض
يعني العراقيين العظماء اللي احنا طبعا
يعني العراق دوله عزيزه جدا على قلوب كل
العرب وقلوب الكويتيين زي ما قالت
مشاري الكاتبه مؤكد لكن الحساسيه ساعات
بتجعلنا نرى اشياء مش موجوده فهي
حاله متكرره بتحدث اول ما تقدم عمل فني في
اكتر من جنسيه وقد يكون هناك في الخلفيه
زي العمل اللي قبله النار بالنار هتلاقي
اللي انتم اتكلمتوا عنه هتلاقي السوري
واللبناني مؤكد انه اذا المخرج يعني تحرر
من فكره التركيبه الهندسيه قد ينتقدوا
البعض سواء من سوريا او من لبنان هي دي
المشكله الحساس زائده بس لا يعني في
جنسيات في جنسيات يعني والخلط بينهم يعني
موضوع حساس اصلا وشائك ومعقد يعني تاريخ
فيما بينهم على كل حال خلينا نروح كمان
لموضوع ثاني ملفت استاذ طارق اليوم
مسلسلات تتحدث عن خمسه عشره حلقه اصبحت
تسيطر على ثلث الكعكه الدراميه الرمضانيه
ان صح التعبير ما رايك في هذه
السلسلات الجديده مثلا من العدد الحلقات
القصيره
قصيره او طويله احنا بنقيس الدراما بالحيز
اللي عايز الزمني اللي هو زمن الدرامي
اللي بتشغله المشكله كانت عندنا في
الدراما العربيه ان احنا كلنا استسلمنا
لرقم 30 عشان خاطر رمضان 30 يوم طبعا
والفضائيات بتبيع بتشتري الاعمال الدراميه
دي فاصبح الكاتب دايما بيضطر يكمل الحكايه
باشياء بره النص لمجرد انه عايز يملا 30
حلقه انا سميتها صراع الورقه البيضاء انا
عايز يملى وكتير من الاعمال الفنيه تبدا
جيده جدا ثم في السكه يبتدي الكاتب ما
يبقاش على قدر ما عندوش حاجه يقولها فاضطر
يقول اللي اتقال ودي مشكله كبيره المنصات
الحقيقه لعبه دور لما قدمت اعمال سبع
حلقات ثمان حلقات 12 حلقه 15 20 المهم لم
تتقيد بالرقم الثلاثين مش معنى كده انه اي
عمل 30 حلقه يبقى في مطوه تطوير ممكن
العمل الدرامي استوعب 30 وممكن 35 وممكن
الحلميه كانت 150 حلقه باب الحاره المسلسل
السوري ممتد يعني يعني
ضيف دائم معنا شكرا يا استاذ طارق الشناوي
من القاهره ناقد الخندق